and look there's an argument to be made
to never use a first round pick on a
running back unless it's a guy you
really love who you think is going to be
great you can find running backs later
in the draft round two round three all
the way around seven all the way to
undrafted like an arianes foster aryan
foster excuse me so uh i
i it it's amazing to see how some of
these careers unfold and we've talked in
recent weeks about the christian
mccaffrey second contract other guys who
are in line for one
22 running backs were taken in the 2015
draft chris and currently
none
are playing for the teams that drafted
them we are five years removed from that
draft and the 22 running backs taken are
not with the teams that took them todd
gurley cut by the rams signed by the
falcons melvin gordon not re-signed by
the chargers he signed with the broncos
david johnson traded to the texans after
a contract that the cardinals ended up
regretting tevin coleman long gone from
the falcons um
so you know it raises questions about
will teams continue to recommit and look
at the recent history of second
contracts
more regrets
than rewards
you know the biggest argument to not
give christian mccaffrey a huge contract
was look at what happened with todd
gurley look at what happened with
ezekiel elliott you know and not that
ezekiel was bad last year but he was no
longer that that
clear-cut top running back in the game
he wasn't playing at the level that they
paid him at
and uh i you know you just have to
wonder
what teams are going to do with this
next wave of running backs who are due
for their second contracts chris
yeah well i think you know the the new
the new wave of thinking and i know
we've touched on this a little bit
but when you do draft a running back i
don't care if you draft him in the first
round the second round the third round
whatever it may be
you know we have to get out of this old
world thinking of oh we drafted our
running back and he's our guy for the
next seven or eight years no it's a
three to four year investment every
three years teams should be probably
looking at going all right we need to
draft the running back the bolster the
room for depth or maybe wait we need to
we need a higher pick to get you know
some some higher quality athlete in here
at the running back position however
these teams want to use their
investments or assets as far as draft
picks are concerned but that's really i
think as far as you can go i mean you're
right we got examples to show you that
after you when you get after year four
it gets dangerous it does and i think
that's how it has to be evaluated one
you have to realize you're drafting a
running back for the short term we're
gonna see how it goes and really
then you have to evaluate the three to
four years that the running backs there
and go okay how much wear and tear has
he had where is he at physically and
that should be what dictates how much
you're gonna pay the guy in the future
and all that i think that's why carolina
didn't blink with christian mccaffrey
one they know how awesome he was but two
they looked at him and they go man he
takes care of his body he hasn't really
been banged up so far i think this is a
safe investment as far as giving her
running back money and they deemed that
and then they went with it so that's
what teams i think i have to do here as
we go on with the running back uh the
running back position
and this is one of the realities of
having a workhorse running back he
becomes a superstar he becomes a favor
of the fantasy football crowd he becomes
a guy that all your fans buy his jersey
he's the face of your franchise that's
what the panthers are dealing with and
the challenge becomes if he ever gets to
the point where he's not living up to
that contract it's a lot harder to rip
the name off the back of the jersey and
move on because the fans aren't going to
want to do it you're stuck with that guy
and you may be in a position where you
end up keeping him longer than you ever
would have because of the fact that he's
become the superstar force in your
organization that's part of the reason
why you don't give the guy the second
contract that's part of the reason why
you have two or three running backs so
you never have that one guy who burns so
brightly you have to give him the big
contract i mean look what the clients
have done with marlon mack marlon mack
was on the list of guys that maybe are
going to get a second contract not
anymore not not now that they've signed
or drafted jonathan taylor and signed
him to a rookie contract that that's
that's part of that willingness you have
to have as a team that's a position that
churns
and
if you do that long-term big money deal
with that guy who's become a superstar
you may regret it quickly like the rams
did with todd gurley the original guy
chris the first guy who who who brought
this dynamic to light was sean alexander
sean alexander was a guy the seahawks
didn't know what they were going to do
well we were going to sign him or what
2005 he has an mvp season well we got to
sign him we got to give him big money
everybody loves him he's the he's the
the core of our offense and then one
year later they couldn't wait to get rid
of him and and we still see that we
still seem to see teams fall into that
trap because i think they back
themselves into a corner and they have
no choice at that point
well yeah i mean you know i think the
dallas cowboys they'd be one of those
teams you could look at and listen i
know we both were sitting here pounding
on the table hey ezekiel elliott get
your money do all those things
uh we're always in favor of seeing the
player get their money but you know i
think dallas yes when you draft a
running back like ezekiel elliott as a
top five draft pick and then
make him
to what you're saying mike the real
focal point of the offense and don't
have a running back rotation
you know starting part of your team's
belief in dna is man ezekiel elliott our
team was built for him to be that guy
can we really win if he's not in there
can we still be as good so dallas backed
themselves into that corner a little bit
and that's the perfect example and yeah
last year was a good year by ezekiel
elliott but i think you and i were
underwhelmed a few times and we were
sitting there on sundays watching and at
nbc sports going man that's a big hole
man there's only one guy within a
30-yard area here for him to make
somebody miss and do it and he didn't do
it so that's where uh again it's going
to be really on these football teams to
make sure they replenish the position
and then evaluate the guy who's playing
that position to see where they're at
like mike where who would you rather be
you know like a guy like alvin kamara i
look at him right now
he's going to be up for a new deal he's
a big important part of that offense
there but they've used a little bit of
running back by committee in the in new
orleans so he might get a few more years
on his career right but he might not be
able to ask for the big type of money
that like a christian mccaffrey got
because his stats aren't going to
justify it because he's been part
of a committee running back backfield
and that's where teams are going to have
to balance it out and even players are
going to have to start talking about
that seeing where they want what teams
they want to play on as far as the
situation is concerned yeah you know i
think the saints would say that carry
for kerry yard for yard camaro is better
than mccaffrey they just don't use them
as much but how do you pay a guy that
you don't use as much you got to justify
that salary you know i get a kick out of
this because any anytime
we talk about ezekiel elliott and his
contract and his performance there's one
specific viewer who will send
hostile profane nasty emails
because
we are the ones that this person blames
for ezekiel elliot having a down year
because we encouraged him chris to hold
out and as we were talking about it
today i thought you know what i bet i'm
gonna have a fresh email from this guy
who hate watches the show
and i did
so good morning vince we hear you we see
you and we appreciate you watching even
though you think you hate us you know
you can't live without us and i'll just
say this too vince has recently
suggested chris that we begin arguing
that saquon barkley should hold out this
year he can't there's no reason to hold
out he's got to have three years in next
year vince get back to us maybe we'll be
arguing that saquon barkley should hold
out that's when the window opens on his
second contract well what's vince mad at
i mean he's mad that we've we pounded on
the table for zeke to get more money i
mean yeah we want to see him get more
money now it's not our job to make sure
he stays in shape and is a professional
in the meantime i mean that's on him so
you know again i i don't know what to
say there you know yes we're always in
favor of the player getting the money
over the billion dollar owner and
ezekiel elliott has put in he put in a
lot of wear and tear in his body his
first few years of the dallas cowboys
but now you can't blame us for
telling him to hold out and getting more
money that's crazy
i can't even begin to paraphrase the
emails that this guy sends they are so
hostile and so profane it's actually
entertaining and i think i'm i'm
encouraging him and others to do the
same thing hey i just want to make sure
our friends in the uk and ireland
watching on sky sports understand i
don't really like it i don't enjoy it so
don't send me i'm serious i'm i'm trying
to make this point clearly do not send
me a bunch of hostile profane emails i
don't get some perverse pleasure out of
that all right let's i don't know about
that uk or england let's just send them
the emails and find out the hardest
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports